quand est ce que je serai remboursé
puis je faire une cure thermale cette
année je pars en vacances à l'étranger
est ce que ma mutuelle voyage avec moi
vous avez toujours plein de question
pour nous et c'est tant mieux car nous
sommes là pour y répondre
téléphonez nous ou demander à être
rappelé tout est clair et précis sur
notre site
une mutuelle qui vit avec vous votre
quotidien
c'est ça une mutuelle qui va bien
revenez clic et on en parle
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
second numéro de check up votre émission
santé et bien-être
au programme de ce numéro retour sur la
semaine bleue une semaine consacrée au
troisième âge nous avons participé aux
différents ateliers à versailles et à la
verrière et pour la journée
internationale des personnes âgées
l'association les petits frères des
pauvres est allé à leur rencontre à
l'hôpital de plaisir grignon et pour
terminer le premier changed man débarque
en france l'association hf prévention a
lancé son nouveau jeu interactif virus
oise place de la bastille nous l'avons
testé pour vous et pour commencer ce
magazine l'hôpital privé de trappes
s'est mis aux roses pendant une semaine
ou des événements étaient organisés dans
le cadre du mois octobre rose pour
sensibiliser à la lutte contre le cancer
du sein
rappelons que chaque année ce sont 49
mille femmes qui sont touchées par cette
maladie qui reste la première cause de
mortalité par cancer chez la femme
on écoute aurélia mais s'est dit me qui
était le 2 octobre dans l'établissement
le dépistage organisé c'est vraiment
pour les 50-74 ans avec une prise en
charge totale de la mort a fini avec la
palpation
après il ya certaines femmes qui vont
passer des examens plutôt bien souvent
parce qu'il ya des antécédents familiaux
tout en sachant que ces 5 % des cancers
seulement donc finalement dire que qu'on
n'a pas besoin de faire une mammographie
parce qu'il n'a pas d'antécédents
familiaux
c'est pas une raison suffisante bien
souvent les femmes n'y vont pas parce
qu'elles craignent la douleur puisque
une mammographie c'est pas agréable il
ya une compression du sens mais c'est de
leur faire entendre que c'est une
douleur à très court terme pour pouvoir
éviter des douleurs à long terme à
savoir un cancer qui sera détecté à un
stade trop avancé
retour maintenant sur la semaine bleue
une semaine où le troisième âge étaient
à l'honneur dans plusieurs villes du
département des thèmes différents selon
les communes
lutter contre le cloisonnement des
générations et faire valoir le rôle des
aînés dans notre société à la verrière
ou encore promouvoir expliqué la santé
numérique à versailles
reportage des choses est bien des
rencontres inter générationnelles à la
verrière le statut disparaît ici pas
d'enfants de personnes âgées que l'on
ait dix ans 70 aujourd'hui tous sont
citoyens du monde permettent d' à des
enfants et à des seigneurs de réfléchir
de co réfléchir où chacun est un
interlocuteur valable ou xhaka a quelque
chose à apporter à l'autre c'est d'une
extrême richesse l'exercice du jour
s'exprimer chacun son tour sur une
question philosophique
aujourd'hui on parle de rêve et quelle
que soit la génération les réponses ne
sont pas si différentes
pas celui ci
j'en rêvais de trouver nos bacs
les personnages y sont pas complètement
différent des enfants j'ai appris que
des fois nous on fait on fait des rêves
et qu'on perd ce cas nous et que eux ils
pensent à tout va quinze personnes
jusque je suis guère une surprise ses
enfants il y en a quand même qu'ils ont
qui savent réfléchir qu'ahmed ouyahia
d'éphémères mais quand même des enfants
qui recherchent quand même et nous
devons leur apporter notre notre
expérience de notre vécu une semaine
bleue ponctuée d'activités en tous
genres pour le troisième âge ici un tout
autre exercice petite initiation au
self-défense ces retraités se prête
volontiers au jeu mais admettent tout de
même ne pas être vraiment à l'aise avec
ces techniques pour femmes
oui ça serait peut-être plus difficile
de se défendre can am je vais peut-être
montré nerveux malgré les difficultés
rencontrées la bonne humeur reste
palpable
une semaine qui a ravi tous les
participants mais qui est surtout la
meilleure occasion de revaloriser des
seniors dans notre société
commercialise pilote c'est ce bouton
donc on va le fixer sur les boîtes de
médicaments donc soit directement comme
un trombone soit alors avec à l'aide
d'un élastique sur tous types de
supports soutient les flacons les tubes
on programme son ordonnance au
smartphone alors de prison plus aux
boutons c'est clair et le smartphone
sonne en rappelant la deux ans qu'il
faut prendre trois cuillères à soupe de
tels médicaments jeux de mémoire alarme
ou tensiomètre ces objets ont tous un
point en commun ils sont connectés lundi
à versailles dans le cadre de la semaine
bleue autour de la santé numérique les
seniors étaient invités à découvrir ces
nouvelles technologies des appareils
innovants qui peuvent faciliter la vie
mais aussi poser quelques difficultés
d'utilisation à l'attention d'un public
senior la volonté de les maintenir dans
tous les événements de la vie on veut
absolument qu'il soit à la fois
bénéficier et puis qu'ils ne soient pas
victimes de ce développement un petit
peu a considéré parfois un petit peu
inquiétant les nouvelles technologies
conférence sur l'innovation et
démonstrations de ces objets l'objectif
n'est pas de vendre mais de rassurer une
génération qui peut parfois se sentir
éloigné de cet univers qu'elle ne
maîtrise pas oui ça me donne envie
sauf que ce n'est pas les moyens
c'est certain très utile surtout c'est
ce que je recherche pour ma mémoire que
qui file des objets qui répondent à un
besoin réel pour les seniors ou leurs
familles seulement voilà le prix
généralement trop élevé pose souvent un
problème d'accessibilité bien vieillir à
domicile en étant connecté ce n'est pas
encore donné à tout le monde
le 1er octobre était la journée
internationale des personnes âgées pour
cette occasion l'association les petits
frères des pauvres étaient mobilisés
pour lutter contre l'isolément qui
touche le troisième âge
accompagné de lycéens ils se sont rendus
à l'hôpital de plaisir grignon pour
rencontrer et soutenir ces personnes ont
regardé un reportage préparé par sephora
namani aujourd'hui jeudi 1er octobre est
célébrée la journée internationale des
personnes âgées l'association les petits
frères des pauvres se mobilisent à
l'hôpital de plaisir grignon pour lutter
contre l'isolément des personnes âgées
beaucoup de personnes âgées sont isolés
que l' isolement ça n'est pas simplement
en domicile à la maison c'est également
des personnes âgées en hébergement
collectif qui lorsqu on va les voir nous
disent je n'ai pas de visite
je vois des personnes qui viennent me
voir faire des soins pour s'occuper de
moi mais je n'ai personne qui vient nous
voir tous moi et elles nous disent
vraiment voilà ça m'a changé ma vie des
petits frères des pauvres c'est ma
famille donc ce sont des choses dès
qu'ils sont vraiment précieuse pour nos
bleus pour cette action spéciale les
fleurs de la fraternité des lycéens
étaient invités à partager cette journée
avec les résidents de l'hôpital chansons
dans ses remises d'heureuses pour cette
belle rencontre intergénérationnelle
paul tous les résidences apporte de la
joie parce qu'il y en a beaucoup qui
n'ont pas non plus en plus de familles
qui partent plus en vacances qui qui
restent longtemps dans les services je
pense apporter le sourire patients âgés
la joie est
or la fraîcheur apportée nouvelle
expérience des choses qu'elle a vécu que
moi je n'ai pas encore vécu ce cube bref
encore jeune nouvelle rencontre
intergénérationnelle le 16 décembre
prochain où les résidants de l'hôpital
sont attendus au lycée sonia-delaunay de
villepreux pour fêter noël et c'est une
grande première en europe l'association
achète prévention a lancé son nouveau
jeu interactif pour sensibiliser à la
lutte contre le sida
située place de la bastille du 15 au 20
octobre le jeu présenté sous la forme
d'un laser game géant invité les
participants à détruire le virus du sida
à l'aide de pistolets laser un nouveau
moyen plus ludique de faire prendre
conscience aux jeunes de l'importance du
dépistage changer les comportements tout
en s'amusant c'est maintenant possible
avec virus soir le jeu interactif lancé
par hachette prévention place les
participants à l'intérieur d'un être
humain
fonctionnant sur le principe de
lasergame les joueurs équipés de fusils
d'assaut ont pour mission de détruire le
virus du sida
les rues soir c'est relativement simple
les gens viennent on va les miniaturiser
on va les injecter dans une personne qui
est nouvellement donc séropositives et
ils vont pouvoir essayer et tenté de
tuer le virus du sida à coups de
pistolet laser et chaque prix tir de
pistolet laser permet effectivement donc
d'avoir des tiers de trithérapie chaque
détail compte pour une immersion
complète dès leur arrivée les
participants sont équipés et visionne un
film qui les conditionne dans un univers
futuriste pour cause les jeunes restent
la cible principale de cet événement les
jeunes je protège moindres - paraît-il
donc je crois que c'est toujours très
important de
le pouvoir les raisons ludique j'ai fait
un peu le propos de montrer qu'il faut
faire attention et protégés jeudi
c'était capitaine sergent je sais plus
fraîches de désordre en tout cas dans le
désordre jeu donnait des ordres un champ
de bataille de 250 m² dans lequel est
plongé le joueur dans le noir
principalement un enchevêtrement de
sallesobscures symbolisons les organes
humains un sujet grave pour une
expérience qui elle se fait dans la
bonne humeur
je pense que pour les jeunes ce sera
bien salée sursis misera vachement c'est
super et c'est pas toujours facile de
tuer les virus donc attention chaque
année en france et plus de 7000
nouvelles personnes qui sont
diagnostiquées séropositives et 30000
qui ignorent leur statut virus soir une
grande première en europe qui devrait
voir le jour dans d'autres villes
françaises
et pour terminer ce magazine voici
l'agenda de dates à retenir ce mois ci à
maurepas tout d'abord le pôle santé et
le ccas propose une conférence pour
découvrir le mécanisme de votre mémoire
afin de mieux comprendre comment elle
fonctionne et pourquoi il est important
de la stimuler pour y assister
rendez vous à l'hôtel de ville le 4
novembre à 14 heures et puis tous les
premiers mardis du mois à trappes sont
organisés des séances de vaccination
gratuite en présence d'un médecin pour
pouvoir en profiter rendez vous dans les
locaux de lits ps de 14 à 16 heures
voilà check up c'est maintenant terminé
quant à moi je vous donne rendez-vous
dans deux semaines pour un prochain
numéro
et d'ici là prenez soin de vous